I definitely do not get sucked into the
mindset that these things are inherently
top-heavy or front end costly or
anything it's absolutely not true it was
possible to do it much more efficiently
than a lot of people told us was the
case when we kind of surveyed the
landscape of what was out there in this
particular sector even of IT stuff and
we dug around a little to sort of
investigate what kind of costs labor
what goes into this we were pretty
stunned to find out what people were
spending on the front end to engineer
these things put them up we had a really
hard time figuring out what people were
spending all that money on to create we
think very bad products what is possible
for a young person with an idea in terms
of executing it today even more than
five years ago certainly more than ten
years ago in terms of the speed with
which you can engineer things the
software that's available in an
open-source way for you to construct
these things suffice to say I think if
people knew what it what it cost us to
set crowdrise up they'd be staggered I
think it was like fractional compared to
some of the other big-name things that
you've heard about